Apple already holds the title of the
world's largest company and it just got
a little bigger it's now valued more
than 700 billion dollars the first time
a US company has reached that milestone
these five numbers explain Apple's
explosive growth 74 point five million
apple sold seventy four point five
million iPhones last quarter 10 million
more than optimistic analyst predictions
that's thirty four thousand iPhones sold
every hour every day of the last quarter
the first in which Apple's new bigger
iPhone 6 and 6-plus were for sale 18
billion dollars Apple had a record 18
billion dollar profit last quarter
thanks mostly to those high margin
iPhone sales 18 billion is bigger than
the full year's profit of 373 companies
listed on the Standard & Poor's 500
index 70 percent sales in China rose 70
percent in the last quarter the iPhone 6
and 6-plus
have been a big hit with Chinese buyers
and Chinese New Year next month could
lead to more Apple fireworks 178 billion
dollars Apple and in December with a
hundred and 78 billion dollars in cash
and securities billionaire activist
investor Carl Icahn
has been leaning on Apple to buy back
even more stock with that cash pile
arguing that the real value of this
company should be north of 1 trillion
dollars five hundred seventy eight
percent Apple's market value has
increased five hundred seventy eight
percent since Steve Jobs unveiled the
first iPhone eight years ago
just a year and a half ago Apple was
still battling Exxon for the town of the
world's most valuable company but now
it's ahead by more than three hundred
billion dollars